we have flat Ronnie here at Angie
Tribeca we're all huge Stern fans any
flat Knight is said it's been ten
minutes
what the hell is flat Ronnie when I
heard that flat ronnie was gonna be in a
scene with Mary McCormack I was kind of
on cloud nine
he gave his five-minute warning why is
he coming out how about coming up here
and getting topless any problem
definitely gonna do the scene topless
but Ronnie was amazing he was a
professional wasn't really answering
your questions or acknowledged that you
exist at all it's the it thing you can't
teach it it's all in the eyes all right
up in here you see it in organized flat
ronnie was fine because the drugs and
the hookers and the fast cars the hard
part was really his gentle touch when
Stan I'm the director I think he killed
it he was in about six places in one
scene yeah exactly
I know how he does it it's easy to work
with a human being it's harder to work
with slack Ronnie so yeah doorbell thing
he lingered by the craft service table
kind of a long time a girl and he tried
to insert a lot of the craft service
into some of our female talent
let's get stung a little moustache and
stick it with somebody's ass alright
thanks Ronny good could see in a minute
Wow oh wow you're great man he likes
this position so that works well for
spectating no I didn't say that did you
get yelled it long and hard
oh wait don't I can't imagine anything
figure in my career happening okay
there's no doubt in my mind this guy's
number one
bababooey bababooey no annoying annoying
Thank You Ronnie
let's go [ __ ] some Wars